when we talk about aircraft accidents
uh 80 or 90 are human error so
you know there's so much of the human
involved in
understanding how do i secure my company
how do i secure my my you know the crown
jewels of what we're our intellectual
property
and it's really not you know can i hire
x company
to put this you know exquisite security
system
in in a lot of ways it's it's the people
that you
hire to come into the company so you
know that that's that scenario of hey
you know i'm looking at on linkedin this
person
comes from china they're you know
clearly their families in china which
means the chinese communist party
has the ability to exert control over
them and yet they're in a key position
in my company
you know is that something that that
that that comes up in what you're
working on and
and how does that usually play out when
you talk to if you do
talk to the companies that you do deal
do business with
yeah i mean it definitely comes out
because i mean it's you know you
mentioned china but i mean obviously
there's brain during going to other
other countries as well especially and i
mean we saw that play out fairly
recently
in the news where it was tesla you know
one of the individuals in tesla was
offered
a decent chunk of change to plug in a
usb
drive from somebody from you know a
foreign country in a foreign entity and
to their credit like serious credit they
actually said no they didn't do it and
they reported it and they actually and
they've been a sting operation going
with the agency
um that's huge and i mean i think again
it comes into a risk profile
you know we all we still think of risk
as digital risk we still think
of risk in the old days of did i lock my
front door
unfortunately what tends to happen is
when we bring people inside a company we
automatically assume that they're good
people
we've forgotten this whole problem about
insider trading about
insider situations you know again go
back to the go back to the first world
and second world war you know the whole
loosely
loose lips sink ships mentality is who
has to know needs to know and should
know right those are the only people
that need to know by the way
i know i can trust you because not only
are they on the background but i know
your friends and your family i know
where they are i know the influence is
on them
and therefore i'm okay with it because
i've done my due diligence
we don't do that so much and
unfortunately it's a tough one because
there is there's a balance because there
is some
amazing technology coming out of other
countries
that we do need to leverage and we do
need to work with but we need to do it
with open eyes
you know i mean we've done it for years
we've done it for years with india and
we start looking at where
all the data where all the intellectual
property is going between those two
countries
china being another perfect example you
look at stuff in germany the soviet
russian lots of you and you look at
those next to the woods and go
i'm happy to work with you i'm happy to
bring you in and i'm happy to deal with
the projects
but please understand as i do this just
the same that you would do with me if i
went to your country
i would want to do more due diligence i
would want to understand more what
potential risks i'm bringing in
that's you and i and we preach that to a
lot of the companies we deal with but
again so many people don't think that
way
yeah and so you you brought up something
here that just absolutely
infuriates me because you brought up the
tesla issue
um tesla so that person
fessed up but there there is somebody
that that tesla has sued
for stealing their self-driving car data
by the way
also an apple engineer tried to do the
same thing
with their self truck driving car
technology
the same company that is accused of
having people that bring that technology
to them x-pung
x-p-e-n-g i don't know if you've heard
about it just got a billion and a half
dollars on the new york stock exchange
in an ipo and i'm like
these guys are stealing technology and
in our and wall street is
is ipo in them and that billion and a
half dollars doesn't go to the company
it goes to the pboc the people's bank of
china
this is you know this is the problem
with our with our country right now but
that i see and it really
it pertains the entire free world